[موسيقى]
فن دانات الشواطئ فن مبتكر واماراتي بحت
منذ 98 يعني قاعد تكلمين عن 25 سنه احنا
هني الفنان قاعد يتعامل مع طبيعه الشاطئ
مباشره في انتاج الاعمال الفنيه لذلك حتى
المواد المستخدمه كلها
[موسيقى]
طبيعيه بالتعاون مع الطبيعه اللي هي طبيعه
الشاطئ من مد وجزر وضغط وحراره ورطوبه
ومده زمن
تنتج الاعمال الفنيه المواد المستخدمه
طبعا هي خامه الشراع من سلك من حرير طبعا
وقطن مختلف المواد الطبيعيه حتى الالوان
انت ما عندك غير براده الحديد وعندك ايضا
قصاصات
الحديد الماده اللونيه اللي هي طبعا صد
الحديد اللي يطبع على
الخام دائما نقول دعو الطبيعه ترسم لنا
وعلى قدر احترامك للطبيعه تحترمك وعلى قدر
اهمالك للطبيعه راح تهملك لذلك احنا
مسؤولين مسؤوليه مباشره عن الحفاظ على
بيئتنا وعلى الشواطئ
بالذات لذلك هي رساله واضحه جدا تؤكد على
اهميه حفاظنا على بيئتنا وعالمنا اللي
يجمعنا بمن حولنا من بشر من طبيعه من بحار
من اشجار من حيوانات لذلك احنا مسؤولين
مسؤوليه تامه عن الحفاظ على عالمنا الجميل
ومست هذا العالم
[موسيقى]
الجميل